[Музика]
добре, хлопці, ласкаво просимо назад, і сьогодні
у вас буде урок письма, тож
, будь ласка, підготуйтеся зі своїми
підручниками сьогодні, ми будемо писати лише
на уроці та до кінця  на уроці у
вас буде ваше резюме написано у вигляді резюме що
таке резюме чи знаєте ви, коли подаєте заяву на
роботу, вам потрібно надіслати майбутньому роботодавцю
своє резюме, тому що таке резюме, резюме –
це документ, який узагальнює ваш
досвід та освіту
роботодавці переглядають резюме або CVS, щоб знайти
кваліфікованих співробітників добре наступне
питання, кому потрібне резюме, кожен,
хто хоче роботу, потребує резюме Я
ніколи не бачив, щоб хтось займав хорошу
посаду без резюме та супровідного
листа добре наступне, чому таке резюме
Важливо, що резюме схоже на
рекламу, яка продає вас
роботодавцю, це майже завжди перший
крок до хорошого співбесіди, коли
ви бачите новий продукт, який ви б не
брали, тому що ви нічого не знаєте про
нього,
але потім бачите  оголошення  Vertisement це
яскраве, воно коротке, і це викликає у вас
бажання купити щось те саме, коли ви приходите
на ринок праці, ви
продаєте себе, і вам потрібно зробити
дуже гарне оголошення про себе
, тобто ваше резюме або CV, як
змінилося резюме з  технології 20-30
років тому люди писали свої
резюме від руки або
друкували їх на друкарських машинах або, можливо, роздрукували їх, якби у них
були комп’ютери, щоб люди приносили
своє резюме безпосередньо в офіс
особисто, але тепер з новими технологіями та
цифровими можливостями ми  можна надсилати їх
через Інтернет, і сьогодні резюме
потрібно створювати за допомогою програмного забезпечення для обробки текстів,
тому існують навіть спеціальні форми
для резюме, і багато роботодавців тепер
приймають їх лише електронною поштою або
в Інтернеті, навіть іноді на
сайті компанії, в якій ви перебуваєте.  Якщо подати заявку на «
ок», то приходить те, що робить гарне резюме
.  Ви повинні почати з того,
що у вас було давно, і перейти
до сьогоднішнього дня хороше резюме
має бути ґрунтовним, але ще раз стислим.
Останній урок ми використовуємо це слово стисло, воно
означає короткий, чому стислий, чому короткий,
це відповідь на наступне запитання
і  скільки часу роботодавець зазвичай
розглядає резюме, зазвичай це займає хвилину
всього хвилину
чи ви можете прочитати багато за хвилину ні ви
можете прочитати справді короткий текст, і ви
повинні справити хороше перше враження
, неможливо створити інше перше
враження  тож навіть найменша помилка
може мати
величезну різницю між інтерв’ю чи
ні, запросять вас на
співбесіду чи ваше резюме буде просто відкладено в
сторону, тож я думаю, що я відповів на
всі запитання, які у вас можуть виникнути в резюме, тепер
давайте розберемося  готові до написання, тож ми
почнемо з тем чи пунктів, які вам
потрібні або вам не потрібно мати у своєму
резюме галочкою всі речі, які ви пишете
в резюме, тоді ми переглянемо резюме
дівчини та  ваша робота о  пропозиції і щоб побачити, чи
ми праві, добре, давайте переглянемо
всі варіанти, які у нас є, тому першу
дату народження вам потрібно вказати у
своєму резюме, можливо, так,
тоді прийде сукня, подумайте, сім’я добре,
це особисте чи ваш роботодавець повинен знати
про це, то це особиста
чи ні освіта історія історія освіта
означає, що всі ці школи чи
університети звикли ходити, тоді мова
йде про досвід роботи, якщо у вас є
попередній досвід роботи, ви повинні
записати його, тоді це навички
чи ви пам'ятаєте навички  навички, як-от
користування комп'ютером або м'які навички, як-от робота
в команді, наступні друзі, які вам
потрібні, введіть це у ваше резюме мовами,
якими ви розмовляєте, якщо ви знаєте іноземну мову, якщо
ви знаєте більше однієї, додайте
це до свого резюме посилання посилання
справді важливо, що це добрі
слова інших людей про вас, це
рекомендації інших людей, чому
ви хороший чи талановитий чи
творчий творець із уявою, просто найкращий
працівник, тоді c  номер телефону Omes,
можливо, це необхідно, тому що людям потрібно
зателефонувати з вами, а потім приходить адреса електронної пошти
та улюблена їжа,
чи це особисте чи ні, зараз ми подивимося, я
хочу, щоб ви уважно ознайомилися з
резюме однієї дівчини та її пропозиціями про роботу  давайте подивимося,
щоб ми потрапили сюди, в Наташі і Лейн,
і ми можемо побачити її дату народження
- 15 січня 1998 року, потім вона надає
свою контактну інформацію, спочатку ви можете
побачити тут адресу і що вона живе в
Ліверпулі, вона пише назву своєї
вулиці  номер її будинку та її
поштовий індекс або поштовий індекс, потім вона додає свою
електронну адресу, а потім свій номер телефону наступна
частина – її освіта подивіться, у
неї дев'ять GCSE включає англійську мову та
математику, чи пам'ятаєте ви урок
про британську систему освіти дев'ять
GCS означає, що вона дійсно розумна
учениця і вона керує школою, в якій
навчалася, і знову школа була в
Ліверпулі, потім вона мала
досвід роботи, вона була помічником у
дитячому садку Playland на літніх
канікулах f  або один місяць, це
недовго, і вона працювала офіціанткою в
піцерії Italia по суботах протягом
17 місяців, це більше року,
крім англійської, вона
знає
дві іноземні мови на різних
рівнях, добре, вона володіє французькою на рівні b1
Я б сказав, що дуже високий рівень, і вона
добре володіє іспанською мовою - що ж,
це конкуренція, а потім приходять навички та
інтереси, вона зацікавлена в плаванні на
урсах рятувальників, тому вона не ті
ьки добре плаває, але вона дуже добре знає, як рятувати жи
тя на во
і  навичок, і вона отримала рекомендації
з дитячого садка Playland Антона,
це добре, тепер давайте подивимося на
іншу частину сторінки, і там є
вакансії, на які вона претендує, тому перша робота
- це робота няні, а
робоча  години будуть у вихідні і,
можливо, кілька вечора протягом робочого
тижня, тоді потрібен досвід роботи з
дітьми, давайте подивимося, чи справді Наташа
підходить для того добре, що вона працювала
як помічниця  r у дитячому садку, це означає,
що у неї є певний досвід і у неї
є рекомендації з цієї школи, можливо,
це добре підходить, наступна підошва
та трохи брокколі потребує офіціантів та
офіціанток чотири суботи 10:00
та 17:00.
ну це, здається, ідеально підходить
для Наташі, тому що вона
працює офіціанткою 17 місяців і
фактично по суботах,
тоді наступний комп’ютер кусає
продавець знову потрібен по суботах
з 9:00 до 5:00 і хороші знання
комп'ютерів потрібний ну це непогано
збігається з точки зору часу, тому що
суботні дні Наташа може працювати, але
не підходять відповідно до її
досвіду роботи я наступний мій охоронець
вишневе дерево Дорога басейн
ну новий варіант  а якщо взяти її
навички та інтереси, вона вправний
плавець і у неї був
твій кінь-рятівник, можливо, це добре,
якщо клієнти -
діти, можливо, це добре підходить -
добре, тож ось резюме Наташі, а
тепер подивимося  зніміть галочку з інформації,
яку ви позначили чи ні, так давайте подивимося добре
добре знову в генеральному директорі Natasha ви побачили
свою дату народження вашу адресу вашу
історію освіти ваш досвід роботи
її навички мови, якими вона володіє
та рекомендацію  якщо номер телефону та
адреса електронної пошти все інше занадто
особисте, щоб бути у вашому резюме, я дам
вам ще кілька хвилин, щоб переглянути
це резюме та пропозиції роботи, тому що тоді
нам доведеться виконати завдання з множинним вибором,
так що ще раз де  чи
вона живе, чи можна сказати, що добре, вона живе
в Ліверпулі наступна, в якій
школі вона навчається, якщо якась середня
школа знову в Ліверпулі і які
її спеціальність з англійської мови та математики GCSE, то
скільки часу вона працювала офіціанткою,
там написано  17 місяців о, можливо, вона все ще
працює офіціанткою, тоді вона була
помічницею лише один місяць, скільки
мов вона знає - крім
англійської та які вміння вона вміє плавати,
і ви також цікавитесь плаванням, я
хочу подивитися на  вакансії ще раз, так що
няня офіціант продавець комп’ютерів
мураха та рятувальники добре, я думаю, що ви
готові до тесту з кількома варіантами,
давайте подивимося,
обведіть найкращу відповідь або відповіді, щоб
завершити ці речення першим,
де це робиться  natasha leap оберіть
правильну відповідь і скільки ваших
іспитів здала Наташа в школі жодного або
дев'яти добре відповідь очевидна Наташа
не має електронної адреси
вірна хибна відповідь не дано добре
всі оголошення вакансії для роботи у вихідні це
означає все  робота тільки на вихідні
або була робота, яка вимагала
працювати під час робочих днів злочинність, яка дві
роботи призначені для вечірніх вихідних, так добре
місце няня офіціантка та
офіціантка помічник комп'ютерного магазину або
рятувальник, так що, дорогі, можлива більше ніж одна
відповідь  наступне, на які три
вакансії могла б претендувати Наташа, тож давайте
виберемо три вакансії, на які вона може претендувати, тож
ви повинні вибрати більше однієї правильної
відповіді, і знову це няня,
офіціантка, помічник у комп’ютерному магазині та
рятувальник, добре, хлопці, я даю вам одну хвилину,
щоб зосередитися та  готуйся до
відповідей
зараз, ось відповіді, тож час для
відповідей перше, де це робить
Наташа стрибає дура відповідай, будь ласка,
Наташа живе в прямому ефірі  rpool скільки
її іспитів здала Наташа в школі,
будь ласка, повну відповідь, будь ласка,
Наташа після дев'яти GCS навчається в школі,
включаючи математику та англійську мову наступний
Наташа не має фальшивої адреси електронної пошти
, у неї є електронна адреса
номер чотири, всі рекламовані  робота
на вихідні робота ні робота няні
включає роботу в
будні наступна, дві роботи
на вихідні ввечері є дві
няні та а-ля гард і
остання три роботи включають няню,
офіціантку та рятувальника та Наташу
здається, не підходить для
помічника комп'ютерного магазину добре, все
з Наташою, а тепер давайте подивимося на
Мартіна, подивіться більше, це хлопець, і
ось інформація про нього, тому
ми повинні заповнити резюме під вашим
слова в полі вище, щоб ми отримали
посилання на їх мови електронна пошта
освіта адреса дата народження
досвід роботи навички та інтереси та
мобільний телефон
давайте спробуємо 26 серпня 1997 року,
що це певно  ле це дата народження,
потім йде 94 альбом Street Birmingham
b23 2tf і це адреса, хлопці,
подивіться, спочатку ви повинні вказати
номер вашого будинку, потім назву
вулиці, потім місто, а потім тільки
поштовий або поштовий індекс, добре,
потім приходить  наступний - Моро на my
world.com, і це електронний лист, добре,
потім приходить нуль подвійний сім вісім
подвійний чотири п'ять два подвійні вісім і
це його мобільний телефон до семи GCS
включає англійську математику та природознавство, ще
один яскравий учень, і насправді це
його освіта  можливо, він готується
до кваліфікаційного рівня, а потім цілується тут, у
великому супермаркеті, з касою в супермаркеті, з людиною, яка
сидить за касою в супермаркеті,
і цей досвід роботи такий французький a -
німецький a - ah іноземні мови, які він
знає під своїм рівнем, це a  2 і 2
знову, французька та німецька, тож це
мови, а потім –
малювання на гірських велосипедах і комп’ютерне програмування, яка
різноманітна особистість, і це,
звісно, його навички та інтереси, і ос
аннє  Містер.  Williams
Albion High School Park Drive Birmingham,
можливо, є його вчителем зі своєї школи, і
він дає йому рекомендації, здається,
це дуже серйозна ситуація для підлітка, хлопці.
Я хочу, щоб ви знали про одну річ,
зверніть увагу
на листи, які я отримував десятки електронних листів
щоразу  день від моїх колег від моїх
студентів від їхніх батьків будь-які типи
електронних листів,
і це дійсно легко та зручно
побачити ім'я в електронному листі, і
насправді недоречно мати смішні
електронні листи для своєї роботи, і якщо ви
хочете бути відповідальною людиною та  якщо ви
хочете, щоб вас сприймали серйозно, ви повинні
використовувати більш офіційний стиль у своїй
адресі електронної пошти, давайте подивимося,
перший з них — Haute legs 59 на
hotmail.com, а хто ця людина,
а інший — Agnes Dot Alderman на
gmail.com добре я  можна побачити ім'я
та прізвище людини, приходить
chunky-monkey 240 ad yahoo.com ну
chunky-monkey, здається, дуже гарна
, але не підходить для ваших
співбесід, це стосується використання l  ike see
Bloomie's, тому що це свого роду прізвище,
і додайте gmail.com останнє, дуже гарне
, я ненавиджу роботу, а на aol.com Вау,
насправді краще не використовувати це,
навіть якщо ви ненавидите свою роботу, тому зробіть це
як Мігель Гусман на  gmail.com і
використовувати Gmail краще, тому що тоді ви
можете синхронізувати всі свої календарі, і,
можливо, ваша компанія буде використовувати платформу Gmail,
щоб це було дуже
зручно та легко, хлопці, то зверніть увагу на
це та давайте напишемо наше власне резюме, щоб ви
писали разом із  я, будь ласка, підготуйтеся
зі своїми підручниками, і давайте зробимо це так,
щоб до кінця уроку у вас не
було домашнього завдання і ви написали своє
резюме добре, тому ось форма, за якою
ми будемо дотримуватися, я розділив її на  кілька
частин, і ми заповнимо
кожну частину добре, тож давайте почнемо з
першої, я зроблю вигляд, що я той
хлопець, про якого ми говорили на попередніх
хвилинах уроку, тому назву запишіть,
будь ласка,
своє ім'я, а я напишу Мартін, тоді виглядайте краще
дата народження і я пишу  його
дату народження ви пишете свої дати народження
і 26 серпня 1997 року, потім йде контактна
інформація, перша інформація - це
адреса Мартіна, це 94 Albion
streets Birmingham be 23 to TF
, хлопці, запишіть вашу поштову адресу та почніть
з номера  ваш будинок по
вулиці
закінчив місто, а потім поштовий індекс або
поштовий індекс добре наступний, і ви можете
побачити значок, це ваша електронна пошта для нього
, завтра додайте мій worldcom, тому запишіть
свою електронну пошту, і якщо у вас немає
пристойна адреса електронної пошти зроби це, і це має
бути дуже просто, моя просто Ольга, чувак
jisuk / @ gmail.com дуже легко
зрозуміти і дуже легко побачити, хто надіслав
вам решітку, останній
номер телефону, тому запишіть дерева ваш
номер телефону  але тримайте інформацію в
таємниці, нікому не розповідайте це добре,
наступне місце під, звичайно, вам
потрібно додати зображення, і це зображення має
бути формальним, ви бачите, що цей хлопець носить
костюм і краватку під ним, здається,
привітний і усміхнений с  o використовуйте офіційну
фотографію, а не фотографію з вашої
відпустки чи з пляжу, а
офіційну в офіційному одязі. Гаразд, давайте,
тоді прийде освіта для Мартіна, це
правда, що він склав сім GCS, і
вони включали англійську математику та природознавство
минулого року,
ви опублікували свій  перші тести з української мови, щоб
ви могли сказати, що я склав три завдання,
включаючи українську математику та англійську,
наприклад, або українську математику та історію чи
будь-який інший предмет, який ви склали,
і скажіть, що ви закінчили свою базову
освіту, а тепер, коли ви в 10 класі,
потім настає  досвід роботи, якщо у вас
вже був досвід роботи, ви
повинні його записати, але якщо у вас не
було досвіду роботи і насправді у
кожного було таке резюме, де
це не було заповнено, тому що ми всі повинні
починати з чогось, ніж піти  це пусто
, не бреши про свій досвід роботи, а
для Мартіна це правда, що він працював
касиром у великому супермаркеті добре,
запишіть будь ласка, ваш ви маєте
написати освіту на вул.  їв свою освіту,
потім досвід роботи та свій
досвід роботи або залиште це поле пустим,
наступне. Мови для Мартіна Французький
рівень a - я німецький рівень a - можливо,
деякі з вас знають польську мову, можливо, деякі з
вас знають іспанську італійську, а багато, можливо,
китайську або  Корейська Я знаю, що дехто з
вас вивчає корейську, можливо, доведеться
перекласти її туди й, звичайно, вказати
свій рівень, а потім прийдуть навички та
інтереси для Мартіни
, це малювання на гірських велосипедах та
комп’ютерне програмування, тому для вас це може
бути те саме або щось інше, якщо  Я був
тут,
якби я був десятикласником, я б
обов’язково написав, що мої навички наші
інтереси – це танці, тоді я б сказав, що
література та подорожі були тими
речами, які мені дуже подобалися, коли я був
у десятому класі, привіт, готовий з цими хлопцями
добре, тоді посилання посилання  це
рекомендації хороші слова від
інших людей, а для Мартіна
це Mr.  Вільямс і, ймовірно, він
його вчитель, подумайте про своїх вчителів або
думайте, що ви думаєте про своїх колишніх роботодавців,
які можуть дати вам хороші рекомендації, щоб отримати
ці хороші рекомендації, ви повинні підтримувати
добрі стосунки з усіма своїми колишніми вчителями
або з усіма своїми колишніми роботодавцями, яких ви
хочете  отримайте ці посилання та
пам’ятайте про те, щоб не мати поганих аргументів, коли
ви залишаєте школу або коли ви
залишаєте роботу, тому що одного дня вам
знадобляться посилання, так що хлопці, перегляньте
все резюме, яке ви написали, чи все
правильно, тоді це остання частина
і  ви виконали свої письмові завдання, і
тепер у нас є час для обговорення,
тому вперше для обговорення ви
коли-небудь працювали на неповний робочий день, я знаю
, що в Україні не дуже звично,
щоб підлітки були на неповний робочий день
але час змінюється, і, можливо, вас
цікавить така робота, тому що
ви хочете мати з собою трохи готівки, а
насправді кишенькові гроші – це не тільки ті
гроші, які ви отримуєте від батьків, можливо, ви
хочеш стати більш незалежним добре, якщо у тебе
була робота на неповний робочий день,
яка це була, можливо, ти працював
нянею, чи, можливо, ти допомагав на
фермі, чи, можливо, ти допомагав своїм батькам у
їхніх компаніях, що ти думаєш про
частину
роботи для мене  підлітки, чи це необхідно, я
впевнений, що це тому, що ви
повинні зосередитися не тільки на навчанні, а й
на своєму майбутньому житті та отримати навички реального життя, а
що щодо наступного питання, як
ви думаєте, що студентам
добре працювати неповний робочий день і знову  У моїй родині
є дві дуже
різні думки щодо цієї теми, у
нас були студенти, які не працювали
навіть на неповний робочий день, вони витрачали весь свій час на
навчання і фактично не працювали, і
насправді їм було дуже важко
отримати свою  перша робота, тому що після п'яти
років університету вони не мали
жодного досвіду роботи, з іншого боку, у нас
були інші студенти в нашій родині, які
почали працювати неповний робочий день з самого
початку навчання в
У.  Університет
деяким з них було корисно, вони мали більшу
незалежність від батьків, тому що у
них було більше грошей і вони ввійшли в
сферу навчання, але були
практичними, але інші відчували себе
в університетах, тому що вони тільки
пішли на роботу і насправді
вирішили зупинитися  їх навчання, тому ці
питання дійсно важко обговорювати, але ви
повинні подумати над ними та прийняти
власне рішення добре, хлопці, я сподіваюся, що вам
сподобався цей урок, і я сподіваюся, що
ви склали своє резюме під час уроку, щоб у
вас не було жодного  домашня робота, хлопці, слідкуйте за
оновленнями, будьте в безпеці та мийте руки, до
наступного разу,
[музика].